[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sports comme le proverbe le dit
en mai fais ce qu'il te plaît et
aujourd'hui ce qui nous plaît c'est de
parler de sport local vous connaissez à
le concept qu'il y aura dans cette
émission comme d'habitude des analyses
des débats et des duels de haute voltige
aujourd'hui nous avons quatre
chroniqueurs autour de cette table
présentation en musique on commence à ma
droite c'est un chroniqueur bouillant
ils adorent être jetés dans l'arène pour
débattre sur les sujets sportifs c'est
même son passe temps favori
on le surnomme dans cette émission le
gladiateur pierre chevallier du
rugby-club de versailles nous fait une
foule nouvelle fois à l'honneur de venir
sur ce plateau et mickaël grand talent
et vous ça va très bien formés bonheur à
tous comme toujours en meilleure forme
si le printemps ça bourgeonne tout va
bien tout va bien on passe à ma gauche
musique son palmarès dans le cyclisme
est longue comme le bras il a notamment
été champion du monde militaire a
également été pré sélectionné pour les
jo de 1976
un partout qui a forgé son caractère
bien trempé il est aujourd'hui retombée
vous il est aujourd'hui coordinateur sur
piste au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
jean-françois guiborel est avec nous
jouerons cette émission bonjour je suis
très très heureux d'être avec c'est
vraiment je reparle de sport ça ça me
fait du bien donc nous allons notamment
parlé de cyclisme et des championnats de
france qui se dérouleront dans les
yvelines un vrai mais réviser vos fiches
de série d'accords rencontre sur vos
lumières en tout cas première s'éclairer
comme d'habitude on passe de l'autre
côté à musique c'est notre spécialiste
football il a l'intelligence tactique
d'un didier deschamps il a l'art est
parti d'un eric cantona il a toujours la
classe comme
beckham georges gomis président du
sporting tenir sporting club est avec
nous bonjour georges
salut a tous bonjour comment allez vous
je suis très content de pouvoir vous
voir aujourd'hui monsieur je suis
agréablement ému par rapport à cette
nouvelle connaissance et de retrouver
mon ami jean qui a quoi tomber la baisse
dans la classe comme david beckham en
tout cas si on termine à ma gauche
musique après l'émission d'absence y
fait son grand retour dans ce talk après
avoir reçu des milliers de lettres de la
part de ses fans
l'indéboulonnable l'unique les gens vers
le provocant jean luce ex-coach de
plaisir vous fait une nouvelle fois
l'honneur de leur chasse aux cadeaux et
bons jours il que j'en compte allez vous
en pleine forme il ya le soleil revient
donc tout va bien
vous avez reçu des milliers de lettres
pour retourner dans cette émission et
oui mais j'ai reçu pas mal de courriers
anonymes
alors avant de passer au programme de
l'émission ce dimanche 29 avril en
illinois a brillé avec guingamp face au
paris saint-germain en clôture de la 35e
journée du championnat de ligue 1 selon
ludovic blast le joueur de 20 ans qui a
fait ses débuts à 7 ans au club de
rambouillet aujourd'hui espoirs de
l'équipe de france inscrit un superbe
but en pleine lucarne à la 44e minute de
jeu une réalisation qui ne permettra pas
aux guingampais de l'emporter score
final 2 buts partout
georges qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette perf ans blas bon c'est un gaucher
il est monté avec les pros il ya
quelques temps et enfin il ya deux ans
je crois c'est un gamin pétri de
qualités je pense que
son avenir sont sa patte sur le match du
paris saint germain était grande grande
part par là commence ans a disputé sa
disponibilité son comment sa créativité
et surtout mais aussi décisive puisqu'il
met un but splendide frappe en dehors de
la surface
je pense que c'est un gamin qui a été
emmené inventa via cuit banque jeu
j'avais je l'avais vu avec les jeunes et
désespoir les espoirs et puis plus jeune
je crois les 19
les 19 en vrai c'est un tout grand la
condition doit de continuer sa
progression et puis de 2,2 pas brûler
les étapes de bien s'imposer à guingamp
avant de partir ailleurs
mais là lagos il ya une grosse qualité
voilà genre ça prouve qu'il ya des très
bons joueurs dans les yvelines
quand voir un psy comme ludovic place ah
oui certainement il faut guider ses pas
non là je ne connais pas spécialement
mais il faut bidouiller quelque part les
joueurs donc forcément dans le tas et là
qu'il y ait des 18 non mais c'est bien
et c'est très bien et carlos très bien
pour le pôle a pour le département après
vos progrès saga je veux venir y jouer
il est jeune encore gression progression
au fur et à mesure
en tout cas on l'a vu grandir ici à
rambouillet dans les jambes et
félicitations aux clubs de rambouillet
alors comment d'autres ou à rambouillet
ou dans les yvelines
t il avait sorti à la laddh allard dire
qui et qui a fini sa carrière
maintenant ils ont ils ont ce jeune mais
bon après faut lui laisser le temps de
200 posé dans son club formateur et puis
après derrière derrière je pense qu'ils
y avoir du monde à la porte mais ça
serait bien que qui retournent dans les
tonneaux dans notre département si nacer
à transmettre à la bonne tenue à la
bonnie la bonne idée de prévoir à mener
ça serait bien
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de handball et de la très
belle victoire de montigny le bretonneux
en nationale 2 contre le havre
comprendront également de la vitesse
dans cette émission nous ferons un focus
sur un pilote de karting de 9 ans
originaire de guyancourt hadji milhas
mais avant de développer ces thèmes on
ouvre une page football
on commence donc par du football alors
que le psg jouera contre les herbiers la
finale de la coupe de france le 8 mai
prochain le premier tour de la prochaine
compétition s'est joué ce week-end
villepreux club de troisième division de
district s'est imposé dans un match fou
contre les essonniens de draveil un club
classé une division au dessus des
yvelinois je vous fais le résumé du
match vilebrequin et menés 1 0 et doit
évoluer à dix après l'exclusion d'un de
ses joueurs en début de match j'ai loupé
remarques deux fois avant la mi temps
puis les essonniens égalise
en seconde période nous voilà en valeur
le deuxième but de villepreux
les essonniens égalisant en seconde
période on est alors à deux partout et
enfin villepreux l'emportent à la
dernière seconde sur coup franc on
écoute la réaction de l'entraîneur c'est
la délivrance c'est le résultat de deux
mois deux mois de travail délivrance
allait jouer une équipe eu une division
au dessus on va plus loin comme l'a dit
80 minutes 10 compliqué c'est la
récompense comme je leur ai dit dans le
cul message ça reste de france via la
télé qu'il ya les insupportables
salariés ainsi de suite
faites vous plaisir avant tout ce sera
un résultat superbe but sur coup franc
jeu est beau il est beau
la question sur ce thème peut-on parler
d'exploit oui ou non non vous êtes
partagés ont fait un petit duel entre
jean et pierre
je trouve ça très frais on en parle
souvent ces petits parcours de coupe de
france
je trouve ça hyper frais sur le scénario
c'est dire qu'en gros il sont ils sont
moins bien classés le scénario du match
et part en leur faveur puisqu'ils
évoluent à dix assez tôt puisque le
rouge a pas intervient en première
mi-temps et puis vont chercher au mental
aux tripes une contre une équipe qui est
mieux placé que donc je trouve que
oui plus simplement simplement par la
division de la différence de division
oui c'est oui c'est un exploit
et puis de district et puis et puis de
leur fils leur coller leur coller trois
buts sur un surhomme donc un gros un
gros score en plus en trois deux un beau
match spectaculaire
c'est pas mal c'est ainsi un joli
exploit genre c'est à vous pour moi
c'est un bon résultat mais c'est pas un
exploit c'est tout simplement
c'est pour moi c'est un exploit parce
que c'est vous l'avez dit d2 contre
détroit de district donc le niveau la
différence de niveau n'est qu' un pas
énorme
voilà tout simplement c'est pour ça que
je je n'associe pas cette victoire à un
exploit tout simplement
jean-françois en sachant qu'ils font
toujours jusqu'au troisième tour à
chaque fois non 3e tour en général deux
troisièmes tours maximum s'ils font un 4
et 6 4
je pense pour moi c'est ça
sur le match oui déjà la différence de
niveau se faire ressentir entre une des
deux est une des trois des districts non
en version de grosses différences de
niveau entre ni gain est une ligue 2 par
exemple
est-ce qu'il ya la même classe d'écart
non on possède une grande différence
après apprennent aussi enfin quand on
voit le département des yvelines
beaucoup plus plus grand que que comment
l'école essonne on a plus de licenciés
théoriquement on est on est on est
supérieurs c'est comme si on dit
l'armée de chine contre l'armure
scellement qui fait un recrutement le
bassin le bassin est un peu plus large 1
c'est le bassin créer un peu plus large
et donc c'est bien et donc là sur le
match oui c'est un exploit parce que
gagner à 10 c'est c'est pas facile hein
c'est pas facile à 10 avec un penalty
encaissé dans les premières minutes
voilà donc là je dise on peut dire c'est
un exploit sur le match d'après sur sur
le comment le tour le tour de passer
deux tours c'est donc pour moi
pour moi ils avaient ils avaient
peut-être il
il avait peut-être comment ils étaient
supérieurs malheureusement c c'est le
comment le l'expulsion qui leur a permis
de s'imposer un peu plus tardivement
voilà et est ce qu'on vend ses pierres
que l'expulsion plus le but encaissé
dans les premières minutes ça les a un
peu bougé automatiquement je pense que
oui ou non sur des matchs éliminatoires
comme celui là quand le sort se retourne
contre soi parce que en plus ils ont
l'air de dire que l'arbitrage a été plus
sévère envers eux parce que a priori ya
eu d'autres fautes côté draveil qui
était moins siffler ou ont durement si
fait donc oui ça permet ça permet
mentalement et collectivement se
resserrer c'est là c'est là où le
houleux
le scénario tourne un petit peu à
l'exploit même si la différence je vous
l'accord n'est pas énorme
c'est surtout sur le déroulé du match et
houssard sert à ça resserre les
effectifs et sur leur force morale je
pense que ça va leur servir dans les
tours et tours qui vont suivre je pense
que c'est ça qu'il faut il faut revenir
ça se pense que c'est mal gré mal gré
trétout qui étaient contre eux ils ont
réussi à sauver sauver leur place donc
c'est bien un poignant c'est s'est passé
oui on pourrait dire que c'est un petit
exploit les gens ça peut être ça peut
créer une espèce d'euphorie peut-être en
club on l'a vu les supporters à la fin
de des images on les a vus exulter avec
leurs haut parleurs
ça peut créer quelque chose dans le club
et forcément de s'assurer une victoire
ça crée toujours quelque chose quand je
vois la sas a sacré toujours un
enthousiasme et je leur souhaite une
spirale positive
mais bon après encore une fois c'est
vrai que cette expulsion en début de
match les a certainement galvanisé et
les arts ont motivé pour aller chercher
cette victoire ça c'est certain
peuvent-ils faire un parcours comme les
herbiers alors là ce serait quand même
la coupe de france contre le psg
là ce serait pas un expert ce sera un
miracle un miracle à mon avis on n'a
jamais vu faire dans mon avis c'est sûr
et certain
on n'a jamais vu une équipe de ce niveau
là en finale de halle occitane rien
suspecté
non mais là et puis dans tous les sports
collectifs plus on monte de niveau plus
la différence est importante entre les
niveaux tout à fait d'accord j'espère
que je suis assez verniolle un pied
voilà donc voilà dans tous les sports
collectifs cm
le vélo c'est donc le miracle on sait
d'ailleurs un peu spécial de voir alors
que la finale ne s'est pas jouée
de l'aveu de la coupe du monde 2002 la
coupe 2018 que quelqu'un qu'elle démarre
déjà en qualifications pour l'année
prochaine ça sera d'autant plus un
exploit pour ce marathon qui fera tant
de fil boule mais ça c'est ce qui permet
de rester rester motivé georges excuser
un conseil à leur donner pour arriver à
réaliser l'exploit dans cette coupe de
france
un conseil va déjà qu'ils aient en
boutique pour le deuxième tour ça ce but
ça serait ce serait déjà une bonne chose
après comme en 14
après je pense que très sincèrement au
lieu de vie à le coach apparemment un
plan pour la fin de saison et le début
de la saison prochaine mais je lui
souhaite déjà de voir un bon tirage pour
le deuxième tour brillant et par la
suite est bien de pouvoir déjà passé ce
deuxième taux est et comment de pouvoir
aussi comment avoir des garçons qui qui
s'y prennent au jeu qui travaillent au
quotidien qui respecte qui respecte le
plan de jeu et puis bon bah y gagneront
pas toujours à 10 attention tout fait de
ne pas avoir d'expulsion continue à
tirer les coups de pied arrêtés parce
que vous en avez mis deux là deux coups
francs sur sur le match donc c'est une
belle arme
donc je vous souhaite une bonne chance
je leur souhaite une bonne chance
j'espère qu'ils vont continuer à
travailler
donc voilà pour l'instant l'heure mais
résultat c'est un troisième tour de
coupe de france et leur prochain match
se disputera début juin on suivra
évidemment leur partant avec attention
un georges après le football on poursuit
ceux ci ont parlé sport part du handball
en nationale 2 monti le bretonneux en
grande difficulté dans ce championnat
est grand a engrangé sa quatrième
victoire de la saison contre le havre le
samedi 28 avril
score final 23 à 20 dans un match
maîtrisé de bout en bout on écoute les
réactions à la fin de la rencontre
on est parti je vais le match est
vraiment
stress pour se faire plaisir et faire
nos duels et on est vraiment très
contente
à l'entraînement on a fait des choses
simples pour pour généreux mobiliser un
petit peu les joueuses pour les remettre
en confiance
retravailler énormément la finition
parce qu'on avait beaucoup de beaucoup
de duels perdus face à la gardienne donc
ça ça a été le travail de toute la
semaine et je pense que ça a payé
avec cette quatrième victoire de la
saison lésigny montagne pointe désormais
à la 11e place sur 12 équipes engagées
une place anecdotique car aucune
descente n'est programmé cette année
dans la nouvelle réforme du handball
l'occasion pour le staff de tester
certaines zones certaines joueuses en
vue de la saison prochaine
regardez on travaille pour l'année
prochaine c'est ce que je dis à mes
joueuses tout le travail que l'on fait
là c'est pour l'année prochaine
donc allez-y à fond vous prenez pas la
tête jouez comme vous voulez jouer comme
je vais dire comme vous le sentez
et puis surtout faites vous plaisir est
là se sont fait plusieurs la question
sur ce thème montigny le bretonneux
doit-il préparer la saison prochaine
quitte à perdre tous ses matches jusqu'à
la fin de la saison
oui ou non la question ne vous plaît pas
j'en ai un petit duel entre georges et
jean gens vont commencer je vois que
c'est pas que la question me plaît pas
ne me plaît pas c'est que c'est c'est
avec angoisse sportivement cette saison
pour 8 mai s'est jamais ouais j'ai
balayé cette saison alors c'est jamais
bon d'avoir que deux défaites parce
qu'il ya la spirale négative qui fait
que ben après c'est pas génial pour
préparer une nouvelle saison c'est
effectivement il faut qu'il prépare
d'ores et déjà la nouvelle saison parce
que ya pas de descendre comme ils l'ont
dit mais préparer la saison avec une
accumulation de défaites
c'est pas la meilleure c'est pas la
meilleure des manières parce que il faut
justement dans la préparation de cette
nouvelle saison et acquérir de la
confiance et la confiance et bien ça ça
va avec le résultat donc s'il n'y a pas
de résultats on peut pas dire que la
préparation de la saison d'après soit
vraiment c'est pour ça que là que la
question était assez assez
contradictoire par rapport à l'état
d'esprit sportif qu'on peut avoir
lorsqu'on prépare une nouvelle saison
moi je pense plutôt que effectivement il
faut qu'ils préparent à la saison d'ores
et déjà sans avoir le pressing du
résultat ça c'est une chose
donc étant libérés ils n'ont pas ils
n'ont pas un pressing sur le résultat en
dix ans mais si on perd on descend le
cas pas de descente donc qu'elles sont
dégagés de ce genre de pression mais
justement essayer de mettre en place une
spirale positive pour que dès le début
de la saison prochaine mais le groupe
soit un petit peu plus en place et puis
confiance le plus en plus confiance en
son jeu georges
c'est un ouf moi je vais personnellement
enfin je pense aussi que donc 2 2
peuvent déjà préparer la saison
prochaine quitte à perdre tous leurs on
ne joue pas un match pour perdre déjà et
quand on arrive sur un terrain c'est on
est toujours on n'est jamais plus
dangereux que quand on n'a rien à perdre
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui ils ont des
résultats parce que ils peuvent jouer
comme ça parce qu'il peut se le
permettre est donc là les résultats
voilà donc ils ont les remonte au
classement et je pense que quand on joue
sans pression on est encore plus
dangereux que qu'avec
la corde la corde ou le le commandent la
pression du résultat
maintenant dire voilà c'est la pression
voilà je pense que sans pression je
pense qu'on est plus fort on le voit sur
le match sur l'hommage de villepreux et
ben ils sont ils sont ils sont menés ils
sont à 10 bon cela chez console on se
lâche on est beaucoup plus dangereux on
est on est on sait donc pour vous quoi
qu'il arrive même si voilà elle prépare
déjà la saison prochaine elles auront
moins de pression par conséquent elle
gère au mieux selon moi oui parce que la
la comment une équipe une équipe de
hauts murs déjà elle n'a rien à perdre
maintenant ce qui ce qui ce qui la
fragilise
c'est le fait d'être dos au mur des
cendres et des cendres et ça démobilise
tout le monde alors que là on est on est
comment on est sous pression on est
certes mal classé mais quand on quand on
rentre sur le terrain où quand on va à
l'entraînement
bah on peut garder toujours on peut
toujours garder en tête bonne ambiance
on peut il ya on se tire pas dessus et
le groupe il s'effiloche pas et quand on
a un groupe comme ça et qui j'espère
pour eux il est pas trop âgées de leur
dire l'année prochaine on va profiter de
cette année pour l'année prochaine jouer
les premiers rôles je ne vois pas que je
vois pas pourquoi ils paieraient je
pense que c'est laisser le côté relâche
de pression qui fait kiffer effet c'est
pas automatique de leur dire de de
préparer déjà la saison ça veut dire
perdre tous les matches au contraire le
l'entraîneur le dit de prendre du
plaisir et collectivement après avoir
fait relâcher la pression
jouer son handball on va dire tranquille
sans pression de la descente puisque la
priorité un point de règlement qui fait
que l on cette pression là en moins
donc je pense que le fédéral gestion le
président et l'entraîneur avait visé une
place au tableau en début de saison
après il ya une seconde et sans regarder
qu'elle a parlé de romans talent il ya
un gros décalage entre
c'est vrai qu'on avait parlé en tout
début de saison il ya un gros décalage
entre les ambitions depuis l'arrivée
dans l'obligation de gagner en partie au
match pour être en mission dans le mur
y'a pas il n'y a pas eu tant de
différence avec les et avec les deux
trois qui sont classés devant elle il ya
deux trois points au classement donc le
simplement le fait de d'enlever cette
pression de la descente peut leur
permettre de justement de se relâcher
jouer jouer un peu joué collectivement
prendre du plaisir comme l'entraîneur le
précise et et qui sait gagner gagner
d'autres matches
jean-françois voulait réagir non
simplement c'est que je sais par cette
oreille je sais qu'ils viennent souvent
relâcher la pression dans un petit
estaminet à côté du vélodrome il
rencontre les coureurs de l'équipe de
france les entraîneurs et je pense que
ça peut être une bonne cohésion de venir
faire un baptême et ils ont décidé de
leurs entraîneurs viennent
il m'a appelé ce matin et il veut faire
un baptême tombeau préparer plus elle
est soudé l'équipe et c'est pauline
niveau d'ailleurs qu'est pivot qui les
pivots de l'équipe
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait relever votre
petite ardoise vrai c'est je pense que
pour relâcher la pression ça peut être
très sympa de et je crois qu'ils ont
envoyé une bonne ambiance dans cette
équipe parce que les entraîneurs des
équipes de france piste m'ont dit que et
ils savent s'amuser
jean françois parent combien de temps la
vence une saison comme le thym lavande
le plus tôt possible j'aurais tendance à
dire
on est déjà au mois de mai la
compétition là c'est là on la sait très
bien puisque ils n'ont que ça à
s'occuper puisqu'elles n'ont pas
d'ambition de phase finale
encore une fois ils n'ont pas de
pression descente donc elles n'ont que
ces matches là qui sont des matchs de
luxe de préparation pour être prête en
début de saison prochaine
donc là là je pense que le temps de
préparation et d'idéal avec des matchs
en plus des matchs à un jeu pour elle de
vous soumettre un enjeu personnel pour
justement remonter dans le milieu voire
la première partie du tableau puisque
c'était l'objectif du club en début de
saison la saison prochaine se prépare
dès à présent vous vous disais agents
escaut si les résultats de l'équipe de
cette fin de saison on peut être
influencer certaines joueuses de rester
de partir à bien tout à fait non mais
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
c'est pour ça que de me parler au départ
forcément 12e pour nous ce n'est pas
forcément le même discours de coach aura
l'air criant après tout dépend du projet
hermine est 5e voilà tout dépend aussi
du projet présenté par le club et les
entraîneurs parce que c'est souvent ça
qui plaît aux joueurs
cc c'est le projet sportif qui est mis
en place effectivement c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure sur la fin de
saison s'il ya une spirale de victoires
mais il ya des liens qui vont se créer
et un groupe qui va se faire que ce soit
sportivement et relationnelles main et
amicalement voire plus si affinités et
et ça c'est un plus pour pour le début
de la saison prochaine et pour faire
rester les joueuses au club ça c'est
certain
on est on est dans le positif à la
location sur cette thématique
si vous étiez entraîneur jean françaix
libourel de l'équipe qui se risqueraient
la place c'est ce que j'avais en ligne à
ce que l'objectif est ce que le coach
reste déjà le coach te voilà c'est ça de
vrai parce que c'est tout à fait
différent lorsque le projet
un coach qui restent soudés ou qui s'en
va donc voila mais sinon la question
c'est est est ce que quelle place nous
fixerons chose si vous étiez tâche mais
au 12 quand même il faut
faut aussi je pense que si ils vont pas
satisfaire toujours d'une place
comme celle ci donc je pense que la c1
c'est un petit galop ou par ailleurs
d'entraînement mais maintenant faut
aussi envisager d'autres placent donc
mieux que moi
oui oui oui ça moi je sais pas je viens
pour bojan ben oui façon surtout il faut
se rapprocher le plus près de l'objectif
initial du club de début de saison s'est
chargé jorge en a chaque geste sujet aux
fêtes georges on reste dans le même
genre de maule qu'il s'agit d'un cours
sur le foot
donc je dirais que vous le faites pas
abattre lilian thuram je demande quelle
place milieu de tableau moi je prendrais
le le palier grignoter sur le premier le
premier le 11e d'abord revenir sur le
11e et puis 11e ou 12e viser un sixième
visite 10e et puis le 9e et un set de
larges pages résultat nous aurons passé
laisse de la seconde dans cette émission
pour parler à karting
[Musique]
les yvelines pourront peut-être se
vanter dans quelques années d'avoir vu
grandir un pilote de formule 1 jimmy
liasses incluant courtois de 9 ans
affole les compteurs après avoir emporté
ces dernières années le championnat de
france de karting après avoir été
récompensé par la fédération française
d'automobiles il use aujourd'hui sa
gomme sur les circuits du championnat du
monde de karting en italie il a même à
manager depuis décembre dernier nous
l'avons d'ailleurs reçu sur notre
plateau on écoute le but est de faire
prendre conscience à jimmy de tous de
tous les enjeux et de tous les pourtours
tous les petits détails qui vont faire
au final la différence sur la piste donc
jimmy a indéniablement à talent naturel
qui est assez important maintenant avoir
du talent ça ne suffit pas et donc moi
je suis là pour essayer de lui apprendre
de lui faire prendre conscience de de
tous les deux tout ce qui est autour et
comment bien gérer une séance d'essai
calif
comment se comporter avec les
partenaires parce que ça fait aussi
partie du métier de sportif de haut
niveau la question sur ce thème jimmy
diaz doit-il déjà s'entourer d'un
manager à son âge 9 ans je le rappelle
oui oui oui c'est tous unanimes gens
vous êtes un peu hésité contrairement
aux autres payez la raquette
il est vrai que malgré son jeune âge 9
ans malgré son jeune âge bon il est
aussi c'est un sport quand même assez
particulier l'automobile il est obligé
d'être encadré avec un manager même même
si jeune pour pour lui permettre pour
lui permettre de pouvoir prétendre à
évoluer à un haut niveau et franchir le
sait pas le fossé franchir le ravin plus
tard pour être éventuellement pilote de
formule 1 mais l'a pour l'instant quand
même
c'est un coup de poker c'est un coup de
dés il a 9 ans et le karting il ya
seulement deux ans ouais il a tout gagné
puis à ses débuts oui m'enfin bon après
bon il ya certainement dans le lot il
doit y avoir des grains est championne
qui ont eu le même parcours que lui
il y en a eu après je fais bien
vingtaine hamilton voilà voilà
mais forcément il y en a dans le lot il
y en a qui ont été repérés à cet âge là
mais quand même il ya aussi certainement
beaucoup plus qu'un pas franchi le cap
de du karting à la formule 3000 ce que
je crois qu'elle a franchis de 3000
avant et la formule 1 moi j'en connais
beaucoup des super sportif des
adolescents qui étaient très forts
chapelain du monde le champion du monde
de karting et que jamais franchi le cap
après je n'ai fait qu'appliquer voilà
que jamais passé le cap et c'est très
compliqué c'est très très compliqué de
l'amont c'est un gros coup de poker
c'est un homme fin 9 en dur qui serait
d'un grand champion bah pourquoi pas
jean-françois ans que je voudrais c'est
que le karting coûte énormément cher
c'est à dire que pour soi parents les
parents c'est vraiment très coûteux non
c'est pas ça mais c'est que hamilton
c'est vrai qu'à neuf ans il a été repéré
par mclaren
à 12 ans il lui a payé tout tout ce
qu'il fallait pour pouvoir progresser et
c'est moi c'est ça que je vois c'est que
faut pas lui mettre la grosse tête au
monde ça c'est sûr donc c'est
l'important l'important de l'entourage à
l'importance de l'entourage par non mais
je crois que c'est bon quand même qu'il
soit encadré
tout dépend l'intérieur ça a l'air assez
conséquent enfin je sais pas il ya de
plus attirant depuis décembre il mais je
pense que c'est plus pour ça aussi c'est
qu'une orientation il ya une filière il
faut la comprendre regardez ans mais il
a déjà conseiller sur le choix de
l'écurie notamment il sera cette année
cher à tony kart qui est car un
partenariat avec ferrari
il a conseillé sur son choix de
championnat hamilton illégalement avec
les championnats du monde sur son choix
de cartes
finalement il va influencer sa carrière
bien sûr c'est que partiellement il a
choisi faut mettre tous les atouts dans
son jeu mais comme dit jean c'est vrai
que ces jeunes mois pour moi c'est vrai
que dans des sports 9 ans et il ya tout
à faire quoi j'ai eu la chance de le
rencontrer puisque on sait on s'est
croisés sur votre plateau lundi
ce qui est important de noter c'est
qu'il est bien entouré
cdg sait déjà c'est un enfant qui est
c'est un enfant de son âge 9 ans qui a
des rêves qui a des ambitions quand on
lui pose cette question que vous lui
avez posées quelle et quel est votre
modèle il prend y prend celui de son
parrain donc avait il y avait son papa
et son manager il débat local voilà et
je pense que c'est primordial qu'un
enfant comme ça un diamant brut qui
semble-t-il a un talent fou soit bien
doré progressivement puisse puisse
franchir ces étapes dont par les gens
parce que parce qu'il ya un gouffre
monumental entre les différents niveaux
juste contre jusqu'au plus haut il a dit
il a des rêves d'enfants de d'être
d'être champion du monde de formule 1
c'est tout le mal qu'on lui souhaite
la route est longue d'ici là mais en
tout cas pour l'instant il a aidé à un
entourage qui est qui et qui est
bienveillant et qui est qui surveille
bien sûr sa progression avec injustement
à talent brut a façonné comme ça c'est
tout bonheur ça nagerait financier c'est
parce que dans ce sport malheureusement
vous pouvez très bons ou les contacts on
contacte un carnet d adresse et c'est
pour ça que si vous avez la bonne
adresse au départ c'est quand même mieux
ma faim pour moi c'est privé c
c'est le maximum qu'on peut ils sont
aussi de plus en plus jeune georgia
débute en f1 le hollandais max
verstappen a fait ses débuts en f1 à 17
ans et 166 jours sans permis sans faire
ce verdict semble permis chez toro mais
en moto c'est fréquent de voir des
pilotes qui n'ont pas de permis
mais quand on est précoce mais on est
prêts quoi ça moi je potentiellement
jimmy dans 7 ans 8 ans il sera en f1
mais s'ils voient c'est tout le mal
qu'on lui souhaite maintenant maintenant
il est c'est bien qu'ils son tour comme
le disait on le disait tout à l'heure
les amis français jean-françois parlons
donc sérieux faire un baptême avec
plaisir donc donc je suis donc suite à
ça donc ça demande ça demande pas mal de
ça demande pas mal de finances et d'être
entouré pour pour qu'on te trace un
chemin comptes donne les bons contacts
que tu puisses avoir à voir comment
les une bonne progression ne pas
régresser de d'être demandé de pouvoir
de susciter de la de l'appétit enfin de
la bon voila mais je pense que les
parents pour le plaisir le plaisir il ya
les parents sont là aussi il veille on
l'est on l'est on laisse pas là on ne
laisse pas un enfant de cet âge là livre
l'a lui-même avec un manager non les
parents ils sont là quand même mission
sont là aussi pour pour pourvoir un
petit peu tu vois un environnement
familial propice aussi si les parents
sont là 6au des parents sont là et que
leur but à eux c'est que le gamin
fassions une carrière et non gagner de
l'argent seulement je pense qu' il n'y
aura pas il n'y aura pas de souci
maintenant la motivation intrinsèque
d'un sportif c'est d'abord
la réalisation de son projet voilà et
après si on transfère sa une fois qu'on
arrive à un moment et puis qu'on se dit
le 6 à 18 ans ou à 17 ans waheed ali
dans une écurie et pour lui c'est
terminé c'est terminé ils gagnent y sera
pour un grand champion à mon avis il
sera pas un grand champion maintenant
s'ils gardent cette appétence du
résultat genre on sait pas trop de
pression non plus sur sur jimmy sur les
épaules de jamie à la ceni the way je
suis pas sûr
une nouvelle écurie je suis pas sûr que
je suis pas sûr qu'à son âge il se rende
vraiment compte d'une certaine pression
et j'espère que son entourage fait tout
pour lever cette éventuelle pression
parce qu'il ya rien de tel s'il commence
à avoir la pression ça veut dire que
très peu très vite il va prendre la
grosse tête puisqu'ils vivent à se
prendre pour un autre s'il a
l'impression c'est qu'il a c'est qui
c'est qui commença à réfléchir un peu
trop et à connaître la situation
donc pour moi ça c'est pour moi c'est un
enfant quand une fois de neuf ans qui
est bien entouré et qui sera bien amené
avec tous les tout ce qu'il faut mais je
ne crois pas qu'ils aient le manager a
également l'habitude de travailler avec
des pilotes de formule 1 voilà il a
notamment côtoyé des sebastian vettel
d'esteban ocon kobayashi des potasses il
a l'oeil et on peut dire qu'il a
l'expérience 1 par rapport au ps est
très belle voilà ça c'est très bien mais
je pense que je pense qu'avant tout
avant tout c'est l'encadrement le dis
depuis l'hôpital heures mais c'est
l'encadrement gains très importants pour
faire évoluer évoluer ce garçon dans sa
discipline et ce sera primordial
primordial pour pouvoir en faire un
grand champion c'est la base pour moi
c'est vraiment la base parce que à cet
âge là on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
dire on peut dire là il y avait
certainement doué mais après il ya plein
plein plein champ qui font rentrer en
jeu ce qu'il faudrait pas c'est qu'ils
perdront qui perdent le plaisir parce
que
à cet âge là faut que je sois son
plaisir
ben voilà dû plaire en vélo c'était
vraiment dire que le père ou la mère
font des fois mais moi ça me fait même
avec mes enfants j'ai des fois été un
petit peu
excusez moi l'expression excusez-moi
l'expression mais on arrive à des fois à
vouloir faire réaliser par son fils
quelque chose qu'on a peut-être pas pu
faire ou pas su faire et ça c'est un peu
faut être très très intelligent dans la
sphère donc pour résumer
at on une chance peut-on voir pourquoi
est-ce que je vais je vais y arriver à
excuser moi jusqu'à ce qu'ils ont fait
est ce qu'on pourra voir dit mais il ya
100 ans en formule 1 dans quelques
années c'est tout ce qu'on peut lui
souhaiter c'est tout ce qu'on peut lui
souhaiter
mais encore une fois si jeune le
parcours est très très grand très très
dense il faut dix essais voilà donc
échec ou de décès de bruce des mais
est-ce que d'abord est-ce qu'il a battu
mario bros c'est d'abord la base je n'ai
pas cette information
alors j'ai une question gens c'est ça
sera ma dernière sur cette thématique
est ce que vous êtes fan de boxe je suis
fan de boxe oui ça tombe bien parce
qu'on va parler de boxe et ses toits des
parties
on prend la direction d'elancourt marvin
petit le boxeur de la team farrugia a
beaucoup fait parler de lui ces
dernières semaines dans la presse
spécialisée
le boxeur de la team farrugia a défié
sur les réseaux sociaux l'américain
originaire de baltimore j'invente à
davis numéro un américain et numéro
trois mondial petit protégé de floyd
mayweather qui a réalisé 20 combats
depuis ses débuts chez les
professionnels pour 19 k o
nous avons joint par téléphone marvin
petit on les écoute et toutes mes
chances et je suis client soit guerrier
et je lâche rien et il n'aime pas les
bêtes qui rentrent dedans
il est perdu et que c'est vrai c'est un
sacré boxon lava combavas victoire 9 ko
mais devant qui devant keane à peu près
aussi bon les mecs qui titille cas pas
la route et pour moi aussi c'est tout
tout tout se joue dans la boxe et sur un
coup pour rappel marvin petit avait déjà
été champion de france champion d'europe
et compte 23 victoires sur 25 combats la
question sur ce thème marvin petit
doit-il provoqué ce combat oui ou non
quand on voit les caractéristiques des
deux boxeurs
oui non oui enfin un petit duel entre
vous jean françois et george george
comment ça vous voulez vous il a
provoqué ce combat donc pour vous non
non c'était un peu risqué à ces jeux
d'où cette manière non de il faut il
faut il faut il faut voilà que cette
manière il faut payer le show c'est vrai
que dans ce milieu là il ya le show mais
de cette manière là je pense qu'il faut
il faut il faut garder le respect de ce
que les gens ont fait sa carrière même
son retrait un petit peu par rapport aux
autres
il faut arriver puis
réussir par pas par son talent et pas
par la bouche et quand on arrive
bon c'est vrai que iliad et showman il
ya des boxeurs qui sont showman jeux
sont quasiment tous oui mais moi je ne
suis pas partisan fin je suis pas
partisan de cette manière de manière de
faire et je lui conseillerais de
commandes de prendre patience de
travailler puis d'être de l'emmener à
enfin au pied du mur l'affronter quoi
être obligé de l'affronter et puis la si
longue et si le bas oui je suis très
embêté mais qu'est ce qu'il vient de me
convaincre
ah ça va être compliqué alors non non
c'est non ça va convaincre je pense
parce que j'avais pas je n'avais pas
vraiment le le motif exact il a vraiment
provoquer mais une façon vers les
réseaux sociaux
ouais mais provoqué ça veut dire en lui
disant tu es un but et un mauvais je
vais te prendre comme ils font comment
il a provoqué la éviter tout simplement
pas davis je pense que non et je pense
qu'il va il va savoir vraiment où il en
est je pense que c'est peut être une
bonne solution pour lui pour savoir si
l'adulte si là encore à travailler parce
que dans ce dans ce sport c'est comme
tout
c'est un sport qui est très très ingrat
il faut qu'il aille verra si on doit
travailler six ans il a provoqué s'il a
provoqué c'est qu'il
il a quand même une notion ou alors
est-ce que celle de ce bref c'est pour
ça que je suis un petit peu d'accord
avec avec monsieur gomis c'est que avec
georges c'est si oui il faut vraiment
être sûr qu'on fait ça faut être sûr de
soi et le produit mais là je pense qu'il
a il a quand même beaucoup de choses à
faire
c'était une preuve encore de la toute
puissance des rues et des réseaux
sociaux à la doit être ça lui est une
des fêtes peut-être pas la première mais
une des premières interpellations via
via un réseau social
et c'est peut-être là manière maintenant
moderne de de faire de la provoc de
faire de faire de l'esbrouffe de jouer
son va-tout et d'aller chercher d'aller
chercher un match et une victoire de
prestige
pas facile pas facile quand on doit se
retrouver sur le ring mais en tout cas
les réseaux sociaux donnent désormais
une tribune aux boxeurs pouvoir
s'invectiver jean-françois bracq d'ici
là il a reçu la provocation
il aurait reçu mais il n'a pas répondu
d'accord
2 parce que ça peut aussi un réseau le
réseau quoi qu'on dise des fois on n'est
pas toujours
on fait pas trop attention à ce que peut
dire quelqu'un mais bon là oui s'il
apporte lui aussi l'a reçue s'il
apparaît pour l'instant sa réponse en
tout cas d'accord sur le plan sportif et
ce qu'il a bien fait une petit américain
numéro trois mondial alors je crois que
sur le plan sportif on sait que marvin
que 23 ans
marine petit et à la conquête d'un titre
mondial et il veut peut-être aussi elle
a déjà un titre européen
voilà la jane site européenne mais on
sait que ça fait partie d'un des boucles
des boxeurs français qui sont
prétendants à une couronne mondiale
il est certainement aussi de provoquer
de provoquer
l'accession à ce titre un essai à la
fois à la fois risquée pour lui parce
qu'il s'attaque pas quand même
un petit lait comme le numéro 3 mondial
il a un palmarès assez éloquent puisque
il a vingt victoires 20 combats victoire
19 ko ça donc
ils sont harbin 23 victoires en 25
combats et c'était bien beau palmarès
aussi c'était mon palmarès aussi et je
pense que lui dit lulu doit se dire je
provoque ce ce boxeur je fais le combat
et si je venais si je voulais remporter
a rapporté le combat mais j'aurai mes
chances certainement très prochainement
pour essayer d'obtenir un titre mondial
je pense que c'est là sportivement c'est
dans cette optique-là qui qui va
provoquer ce boxeur là pour s'ouvrir les
portes d'un éventuel titre mondial ce
n'est pas trop risqué georges quand on
sait que une défaite en boxe vous fait
reculer de dizaines et de dizaines de
places c'est pas trop risqué sur vos
jambes après c'est son entourage qui qui
voit mais bon de l'autre côté il ya
aussi un aussi une team et moi je pense
que encore sur le jeune pilote honda sh
ag
non mais je ne m'inquiète pas je suis
agent c'est toi qui arrive de vacances
fois qui arrivent de vacances ap donc
voilà par rapport à ça moi je des
prochains jeux même le team adverse ne
va pas ne veux pas rentrer dans le dans
le dos ne veut pas se faire avoir la
polémique
voilà il rentre pas dans le passé quand
même spécial enfin la boxe est devenu ce
qu'il n'ya pas d'instance qui vous
rencontrez le meut le troisième
rencontre le deuxième il n'y a pas
vraiment c c on sent que saison des
combats
c'est celui voilà si cette voie là c'est
pour ça je viens il ya peut-être raison
parce que s'il le fait pas et peut-être
un doute qui va le faire et qui va le
prendre la place de challenger et donc
c'est vrai que c'est un sport quand même
assez c'est difficile de se faire sa
place et en plus si avec wba enfin vous
faire il ya différentes fédérations
différentes catégories
c'est c'est devenu un sport un peu
difficile trop donc il a bien fait pour
résumer ici on passe maintenant notre
rubrique débats
[Musique]
dans cette page débat nous allons parler
de cyclisme du 28 juin au 1er juillet se
tiendront les championnats de france sur
route restait l'argent pense à guy morel
cette année les élus ont été retenues
par les organisateurs quatre jours de
compétition avec pour point de départ et
d'arrivée mantes la jolie dans le nord
du département
au programme des boucles de 21 km 104 km
pour les femmes
253 km pour les hommes et plusieurs
traversées de la scène
on écoute les réactions des cyclistes je
pense qu'il manque une réelle difficulté
pour faire vraiment la différence est
que malheureusement avec
vue qui a pas de quotas dans les équipes
et qu'on se retrouve parfois avec des
équipes comme la française des jeux où
ils sont 26 coureurs c'est très facile
de contrôler sur un circuit comme celui
là et pour réchapper un sprint il va
falloir
une course de mouvement j'aurais sans
doute aimé un peu plus dur mais bon
je pense qu'il ya il ya ce qu'il faut
quand même apprécier les coureurs qui
font la course
c'est vrai que ces dernières années il
ya eu plus dur mais il ya aussi moins
dur donc voilà je pense qu'on peut comme
comme souvent on peut avoir un grand
sprinteur qui peut passer et où alors on
préfère pour les puncheurs
alors on parle beaucoup de cyclisme
amateur dans les ive et avec notamment
la vallée de chevreuse on n'en parle
quasiment à chaque émission on en parle
souvent mais finalement les mises sont
elles devenues la terre du cyclisme
numéro un en france pour les
professionnels oui ou non quand on voit
le nombre d'événements organisés chaque
année
non non vous êtes partagés gens pourquoi
décidé de nous contrarier ou l'ordre
contre je suis partagé pour la seule
bonne raison c'est que sur le plan des
organisations
on peut dire oui sur le plan des
organisations parce que on a eu on a eu
le tour de france on a eu deux des plus
paris nice paris nice neuf années
consécutives dans les yvelines voilà
donc sur le plan organisation je dirais
oui
après sur le plus sur le plan est ce si
je passe plus que plus à la bretagne
où il ya 15 c'est quand même beaucoup
plus ancrée dans normani bretagne
voilà pour moi c'est la bretagne
vraiment le fief
voilà c'est l'ouest celle ouest le fief
du cyclisme et pour les voilà les
raisons pour lesquelles je me suis mis à
lire oui ni non
il ya sûrement d'autres d'autres régions
en france d'autres départements qui le
sont qu'ils ne sont plus que les
yvelines mais même si on peut dire que
les yvelines sont une terre de vélo
finalement les voir on livre la
souffrance on a réuni ce coupe du monde
de bmx qu'a été organisé au mois de mars
il y aura également d'autres étapes
sûrement pas organisé au verdon
nationale 51 dans les prochaines années
ça sent revenir sur ce que disent les
gens c'est là qu'on termes
d'organisation on a été on a été servi
dans les yvelines depuis depuis quelques
années après c'est la différence est
peut-être c'est peut-être dans la
culture la culture de la culture des
cyclistes des yvelines et surtout des
non cyclistes des spectateurs qui sont
capables ou non de pouvoir encourager ou
de pouvoir de pouvoir soutenir ces
événements là il ya des régions où passe
le tour de france régulièrement avec des
étapes mythique du tourmalet et dans le
sud est et c'est le ventoux qui sont
sûrement peut-être plus des terres des
terres de cyclisme parce que tout y est
réuni à la fois les à la fois les
événements et de l'autre côté la culture
vélo qui permet justement de dire que
c'est une que c'est une terre une terre
de 6 mm et est politiquement peut être
pas en faire une terre de cyclisme
finalement c'est yvelines c'est ça peut
être la terre du cyclisme 6
mais les jeux olympiques sont organisées
par généralement dans les yvelines 2 par
la difficulté main 2024 amiens sur 24 et
puisque mais c'est vrai que la
difficulté d'organiser en sont
malheureusement s'oriente pour la masse
on s'oriente de plus en plus vers des
circuits fermés circuit fermé ou
vélodrome parce que c'est beaucoup plus
sécurisant la preuve
enfin les brûler droit les autorisations
préfectorales sont beaucoup plus faciles
à obtenir
non mais je voudrais simplement
signifier qu avant de faire mon époque
je fais pas trop vieux mais quand même à
mon époque on venait à paris pour passer
professionnel c'est à dire qu'on venait
dans les grands clubs à ces bébés csm
puteaux l'us créteil et maintenant on
part de paris pour passer professionnel
on part on va dans des clubs à nogent va
en bretagne on va c'est plus du tout une
terre vraiment de sic avant les
classiques paris esi paris evreux paris
rouen par ted paris maintenant il ya
moins en moins classique qui partent
ça devient c'est devenu complètement
province le cyclisme et c'est pour ça
qu'ils font
oui peut-être amené parce que faut dire
aussi que les championnats de france ont
toujours été montés longtemps réalisés
dans la région était notamment à
rambouillet et rambouillet et à
montlhéry après beaucoup dans les dans
l'essonne les premières éditions et or
voilà et donc c'est vrai qu'il faut
ramener faut réapprendre aux gens que le
cyclisme le cyclisme fait partie de d'un
parisianisme entre guillemets direct
désolé j'en pense non mais on s'est
empressé palpable il ya beaucoup de
choses à dire on passe maintenant à
notre rubrique découverte
je vous propose maintenant de vous
plonger dans la culture indienne une
médecine a été créé dans ce pays au
deuxième millénaire avant jésus christ
son nom l'ayurveda elle est aujourd'hui
testé aujourd'hui par plusieurs millions
de personnes à travers le monde et
notamment à des sportifs pour nous
parler de ces techniques jeu le plaisir
à d'accueillir sur ce plateau une
spécialiste venu de guyancourt sophie
bennabi venez nous rejoindre se filmer
la vie qu'ils ont rejoint au plateau
installez-vous
[Musique]
le plateau est un peu surchauffe et un
genre bien qu'on pouvait le voir
alors avant de parler plus
spécifiquement du rapport entre la
médecine indienne et les sportifs pouvez
vous me dire pourquoi vous avez voulu
embrasser ce concept
alors moi je viens pas du tout de ce
domaine à la base puisque j'étais
ingénieur en informatique donc rien à
voir et dans ma famille en fait on a
toujours soigner par les plantes par les
remèdes naturels en fait et je cherchais
quelque chose qui soit un peu exotique
qui sort de l'ordinaire
à découvrir et à pratiquer en fait du
coup j'ai choisi de
de me consacrer à lier veda parce que
ces médecines qui est globale donc qui
soigne l'humain par le corps par
l'esprit et par le toucher et par
l'oscillation la phytothérapie donc les
plantes par les pierres donc c'est
vraiment très globale en fait alors la
conciliation du coût de cette thématique
est de savoir si oui ou non
l'ayurveda peut coïncider avec le sport
est ce qu'on peut en boîtier les deux
l'ayurveda le sport tout à fait parce
que alors en fait il ya une pression de
pratiquer oui oui tout à fait il ya une
façon de pratiquer le sport selon
l'alluré da pour en tirer le meilleur
parti en fait pour sa santé il ya des
sorts de règle en fait à respecter et en
ayurveda on a des constitutions ce qu'on
appelle des constitutions et juridique
donc il y en a trois vata pita capa et
un faudrait que je vous explique un
petit peu en amont mais on va donner des
fichages ambitieux et en fait ce sont
des éléments qui sont prédominants dans
notre corps est dans notre esprit donc
on en a tous il ya cinq éléments en
alliant d'iéna et ces cinq éléments vont
composer des pères donc les trois doshas
les trois constitutions et c3
constitution elles vont pas avoir les
mêmes forces et faiblesses par exemple
quelqu'un qui est très vas tu as donc et
très fin qui est très dans le mouvement
qui est très anxieux la peau assez sèche
très créatif très hyperactif qui a
besoin d'être très entouré forcément je
pense que vous êtes du pit à houla du
feu ils y ont tous expliquent tout
s'explique
et donc en fait ces personnes à bord
d'un des faiblesses au niveau des
articulations au niveau des eaux dont
tout ce qui m musculation tout ce qui va
être assouplissement justement ça va
être très important de le pratiquer et
tout ce qui va être aussi relaxation
parce que c'est des personnes qui sont
beaucoup dans le mouvement dans leurs
activités donc vous les encres et les
relaxer après une séance de sport par
exemple qu elle revienne à l aide
vous pensez de cette
discipline autour d'un verre je pense
qu'il ya une évolution normale de des
souhaits des sportifs on a vu au départ
on faisait la kinésithérapie après il ya
eu l'apparition de l'ostéopathie de la
mésothérapie aussi sur celle sur
certains sur certains traitements de
claquage ou de ou de blessures
musculaires et il ya vraiment je pense
une une mouvance et il nous place pour
ce type de ce type de médecine à partir
du moment où elle est comme vous le dit
elle à elle associe à la fois le corps
et l'esprit
il y aura peut-être beaucoup de monde à
convaincre c'est peut-être c'est
peut-être long processus mais mais je
pense qu'il ya eu il ya une part
peut-être pas tous les sports concernés
mais il ya une part il ya une part belle
à faire à l'alluré d'ajustement dans
dans les secteurs des sportifs on
connaissait les joueurs qui les
pratiquent fire rédha houhou l'autre
technique non pas personnellement mais
j'ai vu cette évolution là dans un autre
secteur entre la tunisie et le et
l'ostéopathie et la mésothérapie par
exemple par an comprend que je ne
connais pas encore de jean-françois
enlever quelqu'un mais je pensais que
c'était une danse mais ça peut non
simplement c'est tout à l'heure à
discuter parce que je me suis un petit
peu renseigné sur le fait que
vous preniez le sport mais vraiment
toujours
une façon zen c'est pas de own pas en
force
plusieurs à 50,66 moyens c'est ça c'est
exactement fruits en fait on sort du
rapport de compétition quand on fait du
sport de compétition avec l'autre et de
compétition avec soin en fait et c'est
vraiment un sport pour détoxifier le
mental détoxifier le corps on est
vraiment dans le sport bien-être et pas
dans ce partage est ce que selon vous
tous les secours sont concernés ou
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir une réponse de
tous les sports par rapport à d'ailleurs
et davos cas des sports qui seront
proscrits où ça ne marchera pas en fait
c'est pas une question de proscrire ou
pas c'est vraiment une question
d'adapter à sa constitution parce qu'on
va pas tous avoir les mêmes forces et
faiblesses donc il ya des sports qui
vont être tout à fait à proscrire en
fonction à compter de sa conception
pardon à vendre quelqu'un qui a beaucoup
de terre c'est quelqu'un qui va avoir
beaucoup de force musculaire beaucoup
d'endurance donc les sports la boxe le
cardio-training le heat ça y'a pas tous
vélo des sports vraiment bon durant qui
demande beaucoup de force musculaire
aucun souci mais quelqu'un va de vata
quand je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de faiblesses on
va pas et individuels ou collectifs et
une à un traitement différentes vous
avez vous adressé plutôt à des sportifs
individuels tout à fait ça et j'ai déjà
déjà déjà sa répartie un petit peu
ollier de l'équipe de hand là pour
essayer de les de l'ailier ans n'est pas
facile pour nous c'est le baptême plus
d'ailleurs aidé à apprendre et trouver
la synergie globale leur nouveau nous
est on est on est qu en fin d'après
d'après vous je demande pas d'être bas
il ya des choses qui se ressentent
beaucoup de feu chez vous clairement il
ya de la terre et du feu chez vous mais
après je sais ce que je ressens comme ça
ou d énergie attention cela prend du
temps pour les constitutions n'a fait
pas comme chez beaucoup de vata chez
vous samia du capa aussi de la terre
alors sans qu'il vous est quand même
assez d'argent chez moi perplexe je
songe alors à ce que vous avez des
questions à poser à pita où il n'y a pas
non mais c'est tout moi je suis très
curieux je suis très très curieux donc
moi moi ça me fascine toujours
mais ce genre de choses est ce que vous
pourriez recommandé ce type de médecine
à certains de vos joueurs fait oui ça ça
peut faire que du bien
c'est vrai que ça peut faire que du bien
j'avais moi je vais tester
j'avais testé justement sur sur le
collectif
mais c'était vous savez absolument rien
à voir mais c'était quand même de haut
niveau relaxation haut niveau pour la
récupération mais juste juste juste la
relaxation la sophrologie sophrologie
relaxation et pour la récupération la la
respiration et c'est vrai que alors ce
fait rigoler au départ les amener ce
genre de choses dans un milieu
rugbystique g ça fait rigoler mais quand
même à la fin au départ ça rigole mais
après mai
ils se rendent compte que c'est que
c'est assez bénéfique et ce genre de
choses c'est ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure c'est plus un duel c'est
qu'individuel d'ailleurs c'est compliqué
de l'adapter sur un sport collectif
comme le réduit puisque là moi je parle
de ce que je connais bien donc
mais c'est vrai que certains joueurs
pour une préparation individuelle et
pour un match collectif pour une
préparation annuelle
ça peut être que très très bien parce
que le la recherche la recherche de soi
même et du d'un certain certaine
réflexion sur soi même et que ce soit
psychologiquement ou physiquement ça a
toujours été un point bénéfique pour
l'être humain dans sa pratique
georges vous a pas entendu sur la
question et c'est une fin
c'est une recherche individuelle même si
le collectif rapidement vous avez 30
même si elles collectif c'est toujours
intéressant de pouvoir la taille de
pouvoir c'est de pouvoir
comment s'améliorer dit du
individuellement et ce type de pratique
l'époque c'était la sophrologie en
entendez souvent a beaucoup qui ont
évolué quand on arrivait à augmenter
leurs prêts performances grâce à des
métiers sauf à l'équipe je n'avais la
nation elle allie le ciel savoir que
s'il n'y a pas d'image même chose comme
ça pour autant ya pas de oui oui mais je
sais pas être la curiosité c'est
vraiment au rendez-vous après d'un art
question est ce que ce n'est pas
considéré comme un produit dopant
quand ballon l'ayurveda est ce que c'est
on peut l'utiliser fin au regard du
public
c'est vraiment des choses naturelles on
fait avec
c'est l'alimentation les massages donc
cesser de choses vraiment naturel entre
lattes est exactement comprendre
l'intelligence de son corps comment ils
fonctionnent pour ensuite adapté tout ce
qui nous entoure au mieux pour soi si ça
sera le mot de la fin
dernier tour c'est la fin de cette
émission se retrouvent le jeudi à 17 mai
pour une nouvelle émission va terminer
par une citation de l'ancien boxeur
professionnel sugar ray robinson pour
être champion vous devez croire en vous
même quand personne d'autre ne le fait
je vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]